hello everybody and welcome uh we're
doing the third time that we've gotten
together to have this nice chat with
myself
yong
ralph and jake uh who are all people who
make videos about video games on the
internet to talk about how 2022 is going
so far
uh a lot of news came out today but i
figured we would start off with sifu
because i think that was the first big
release if i'm
correct oh we're doing all the way back
to seafood yeah well we were planning to
do this in february and then
things kept happening that's right we
were going to do this in february that
got away from us i think eldering came
out and everybody's productivity just
went and it's among the dreams
and actually dying light dying like two
was the kickoff of the big season okay
that february month of craziness let's
start with that dying light 2 how did
everybody feel about it
i actually haven't played dying light 2
yet so this is one where i can't really
change
up
okay ralph i i did play us i finished it
um i hadn't actually played the first
one so it was like an entirely new thing
for me like i'd seen videos and i'd
heard like a lot of positive buzz
whatever
um i liked it i
liked it quite a bit
um it feels like a million years ago now
kind of i'm trying to i'm trying to
remember about like what did i think of
it obviously when you say i liked it
that's a seven no no that sounds like a
like seven
no because i think at the beginning i
was very much like this [ __ ] rules i
love this game it's so good man i can't
like just this is the best thing ever
and um then you kind of you kind of
settle into a rhythm with it
and uh then unfortunately at that back
end of the game it really drops off
super hard because it's very narrative
it's a it's a very narrative-led
experience
um and at the front end i was kind of
like all right you're doing some setup
here you build some characters whatever
but even then it wasn't fully gelling
with me but then by the end it just goes
batshit crazy and
i mean the narrative gets bad
uh yes i think that's what a lot of you
i would say
yes
yeah like really just
the way it sort of wraps up its key plot
lines the way you finally meet these
characters that you've been seeking this
entire game and the way it handles that
it's just kind of like what that's it
and then the final villain and the sort
of final boss encounter and just the
abruptness of it all but also how
weirdly sort of convoluted it is the
sort of twists don't come naturally i
just was very much like oh that's a real
bummer you know
um
but having said that like the the
gameplay journey throughout it i thought
was really awesome and i was super
impressed by like they have because
there's really two areas to the map
there's like a low like a low rise
setting um which is kind of like old i
don't know i don't know how to describe
it but just like imagine buildings three
or four stories tall and then in the
second half of the game you get to the
city and it's skyscrapers and you get
this like glider thing and it's just
[ __ ] awesome like the the the parkour
throughout the entire game is good and
it only gets better and better and
better and then when you get to that
city you're like holy [ __ ] this is
incredible like yeah how are they doing
this you know
um it does but then as i said once you
hit that point everything starts to drop
off that the sort of increase in in that
sort of the gameplay experience peter
sort of hits a plateau and narratively
yeah it's um it's it's very very rough
how long actually was it
um i actually can't even remember
exactly now but i'm gonna say it's
around about 30-ish hours 30 to 40 hours
okay i think i think 30 to in fact i
think closer to 40. i can't exactly
remember um but it is
in that ballpark yeah it wasn't 500.
yeah
it was not and i actually can't see how
it could be 500 either that's the other
thing i do remember thinking that as i
was playing it i'm like i could see how
you maybe get
200 hours of this maybe but 500 hours
unless there's some kind of metric or
some collectibles or something that's
right every collectible maybe or unlock
everything on the map but even then i
was thinking even that wouldn't take 500
hours besides it didn't make sense to me
i do remember as well like cyberpunk
said something like that back in the day
as well in their like pre-hype period
they were like oh the game is like 500
hours long we're like what and then that
turned out because they ended up i know
they ended up saying
it's not as long as the witcher 3 and
people were upset about that no but
there was like one
who like
he tweeted out that's like oh just
wrapping up a hard mode play play test
of you know cyberpunk and i don't know i
don't remember the exact number of hours
but it was an obscene number of hours
and we're like what this game's gonna be
that big and then it turned out to be
not quite that much so the game length
discussion is a bit weird but um but
yeah overall like i definitely enjoyed
dying light i think it's good open world
fodder it can be played co-op which i
didn't play i think i would have enjoyed
it even more had i done that and it was
quite buggy that's why i didn't yes
that's another thing i mean the overall
the game was was fairly buggy i think
but um but yeah that's uh that was my
take on one it's definitely one of the
ones where
i was like yeah this is pretty cool and
then like after everything else came out
i was like what what game was that
uh
so you played it as well jake
yeah it it it lost me in the end a
little bit but i really really liked how
it paced out all the abilities and the
parkour stuff and this and the skill
tree uh i think some of the stuff
actually clicked in a little bit too
late like the um
the the decisions that you make where
the decisions shape the world like that
whole thing that they hyped up
once it does actually kick in it's cool
say it again did that pay off
pay off
i'd say 50 50. uh
a lot of the narrative stuff no
gameplay possibilities yeah uh just just
the options of having cool ways to get
around uh having new tricks to kind of
like cut zombies off at the pass uh in
terms of deciding between the factions
there's like the brutalist faction
that'll set up the evil traps or the
parkour friends that'll just set up cool
bridges and jump ropes for you yeah i
did the parkour ones the whole way
through because that's just like how i
prefer to play but those choices were
not the choices that i felt like they
kept talking about like that sure the
world visibly changed but it was so
clear to me
even if i was talking to the
peacekeepers or rebel i don't remember
what the factions are actually called
i didn't care about either of them
story-wise i was always just going to go
for the parkour like i wasn't making the
decisions based on the people i just met
give me the climby stuff
it also felt like they kept trying to
play with like oh well they're both they
can both be bad but like i clearly saw
like the parkour fun people building a
little civilization in a church being
the good people yeah and then like the
war criminal people being the war
criminals and the cops being a cap like
you can't
yeah moral ambiguity not quite um it was
forced and it didn't really it didn't
really like every decision i was like
okay whatever and then i never really
felt
too much impact or too much of a
junction point grant that i've only
played through it once but i only felt
like they were like strong junctions
like little bits here and there
i had some choices that i found
difficult but i don't know what the
outcomes were because i didn't i didn't
finish it and i think when i started
playing it i knew i wasn't gonna finish
it i was like okay yeah this is cool and
i'm having a fun time but i'm not going
to sink 40 hours into this i will i will
say i do think your decisions matter as
you go through because they can cause
some branching paths in terms of like
missions you might do or approaches you
might take during missions but i think
in the ending
definitely does not have much of an
impact like in in fact in the last
mission and i guess i can't spoil too
much but let's just say in the last
mission you have to make this really
important decision like and it feels so
pivotal and it's built up it's huge
right
and then
the game ends and then in the
like the post ending credits thing like
it actually basically says to you the
exact opposite thing that you wanted to
happen happened it was kind of just
reversed your decision for you swear to
god like i said i won't spoil it for you
but i was just kind of like why did you
make me go through that whole decision
that really tough decision if on the
next screen you were going to say
actually last cycle
it was exactly that you know so um that
part was a bit of a bummer so yeah and i
think that's like a complicated thing to
get right is like often endings are the
same obviously mass effect 3 and
sometimes it's the journey that's
rewarding but it never feels satisfying
to players if you don't have control
over the ending like that's got to be a
tough thing to
try to figure out and i remember one of
my only criticisms of it when i started
playing it was that i felt like
some of the skills that i
wanted from the start were locked off um
things that i felt should have been in
any like free-running game that i was
like why can't i climb up a wall
properly yet type stuff that i was like
i just wish some of those skills were in
there a little bit earlier uh but
neither of you sound too negative about
that so maybe it like you end up getting
xp faster than i expected or something
i think i did just because i was stuck
in the world for so long like i actually
didn't realize how much time i spent the
first time you're in the first area just
because i was running around exploring
and doing whatever which i think is a
sign of good
gameplay exploration even though it was
simple like that stuff i'm gonna
remember the most about the game yeah
yeah i i think with with regards to its
open world formula it put a lot of
effort like it was it was the map marker
driven thing but it really did put a lot
of effort into making those individual
activities quite diverse
uh and
i would say as well like
yeah i mean
i
i was just consistently surprised or
engaged by that day night cycle yeah um
which is so meaningful because the game
in one moment is just like a chill game
and you're running along the rooftops
and then night falls and it's an
entirely different decision-making
framework that you begin to adopt do i
go down onto the ground and try and
scavenge for supplies and what if a
chase breaks out and whatever
that part of it was amazing i really
love that i don't think any game has
handled a day night cycle as well as
this game super exciting i also love
like you touched on earlier the world
design like the fact that there is the
streets where the zombies are and then
everything vertical of that like has
like a different it's it's like two open
worlds in one open world in a bunch of
ways and i think that's really right
yeah they did a lot of stuff i really
liked
um so that was first then seafood
[Laughter]
i
loved it
i loved it so much
that
at some point i looked because i uh got
through the whole game without age 20
whole game and
i realized that in order to do that i
put 20 hours just into the first two
levels which are only five minutes long
but i was like i was just exploring
everything i was like maybe if i go for
the longer parts and get the upgrades
and then do this like i was just like so
into it and then slowed down a little
bit when i got to the museum because i
found that boss fight so difficult at
the time yeah um but i absolutely adored
it it was it wasn't what i expected it
was so much more of a puzzle
than just a beat em up uh like every
room came about well i know that that
weapon is over here so that's where i'm
gonna go first and i know this person
gets this and this happens here like
much more about like a hitman style
than i expected and i absolutely loved
it what did you guys think
i uh so
the i didn't get a review copy for sifu
and then i got a review copy for eldon
ring just as it launched so i actually
didn't get a chance to play but i did
watch friend uh play it
and it seems like it's right up my alley
because i love those kinds of combat
based games where like pairing is really
emphasized and like timing and learning
enemies maneuvers and like being able to
react to them and all that and it seems
like it's just
uh a focus condensed like concentrated
version of that just in the game
and uh
the the fact that it encourages
basically repetition learning through
repetitions like
i don't like compared to a souls game
per se but it's almost like finding a
soul's boss and you kind of go through
that process
um
yeah
some people might be super frustrating
but for me like i love that uh process
of adapting and learning so it seems
right up my alley and uh the combat
system seems really cool the animations
look incredible it's also really stylish
really good music very stylish looking
yeah music visuals everything
and um i love some of the mods people
came up for it like the neo and the john
wick one i haven't seen any mods
what i've started touching grass more
often and that means i miss a lot of
internet stuff oh my god
no there's a mod that turns uh the main
character into neo and then a bunch of
agent smith's basically damn that's good
they're reloading it's amazing
but in terms of how it feels to play uh
you guys will have to yes jake did you
play it
it's sick it's dope it's tight it's
awesome uh i really like how
like i i like
i don't want to say muscle memory games
but i want to say like like responsive
games or like
like that like like tony hawk for me
like instinctively like like a jump
triangle
grind like is just like so
ingrained after playing it for so long i
i found that with sifu really like every
single
hit every block every parry was like
really like
it sounds corny but like connected to me
like it was very visceral and it's just
like by the end of the game when you're
fighting the low the low level enemies
you
you feel like a god like you feel like
you can actually do that in real life
and i think that just combined with the
artsyness of it where
it is all like really stylized but it's
also really all
uh celebratory like it's like it's hyped
about cinematography it's hyped about uh
highlighting all these like kind of or
referencing scenes from movies famous
fight scenes from classic kung fu movies
uh weapon types enemy types like it all
just like it felt like it was like just
so
down to be there and it really clicked
with me because it really felt like i'm
like this is perfect for slow clap
because i really liked absolver
absolver had a lot more depth in a lot
of ways but
something about it was just slightly off
where this is just
a kick-ass like
linear straightforward video game
experience and for me it was like
totally perfect it almost has his like
it almost seems to encourage like a
speed runner mentality of
it absolutely does so good at this that
you can just freaking you know every
single timing of like when enemies are
coming and you know exactly kind of it
turns like everything yeah where every
button feels like deliberate it's not
you can't match your way through it's
like every button you know exactly what
you're doing in the moment yeah and i
love games like that
i um
yeah i like i i liked it for sure i
think i said in my review i'm like i
usually have more affection for these
games when they're in my in my rear view
mirror because i think the frustration
of it when you're going through it just
like [ __ ] man this is so annoying like
come on now and i'm the same as you like
level two such a [ __ ] holy [ __ ] i just
god that was a tough level and um
frustrating and i think it's maybe only
because
it was so easy to just restart the level
so like as soon as i died i was like
restart let's go i think that's true
actually except for level two which i
think is actually a much well level
one's the same but it's a lot easier i
think but level two i found was a point
of frustration for me because that level
is much longer and if you want to do
that perfectly then yeah it's a longer
it's a longer mission to do it plus one
of my other frustrations with it was
just i found it quite a difficult game
to pass visually you know like the the
telegraphs of enemies in particular the
ones that look like like avatar right
you know with the with the red pants and
no not wearing a shirt or whatever you
know the ones i'm talking about
guys yeah the kickboxer type ones right
they have some [ __ ] that they can
bust out that doesn't always feel the
big guys that got me the big guys
oh the big fat dudes how impossible was
it to [ __ ] dodge their grab thing
that is what i'm talking about where
there were just like little moments like
that where i didn't feel as though it
was fully completely 100 as tight as it
should have been and that caused me that
frustration
that i didn't love i would have only
didn't agree with that because i learned
so like i think there were probably
moments initially where i was dog [ __ ]
and i didn't know what was happening but
then because i did manage to beat the
whole game without a single debt sure
i did learn it's just something a lot
longer than others that's what i mean
yeah like you you can you eventually
learn and then you're sort of like okay
when i'm facing one of those airbender
dudes or whatever this is how i have to
play it whatever but uh that process was
a little bit more frustrating than i
would have liked um but overall yeah i
really liked it more for its style and
what it
did visually and how it did it than for
anything else because that museum stage
was incredible like holy [ __ ] yeah
beautiful amazing just just yeah perfect
you know what i mean like what else do
you want man like that's just yeah it's
so good incredible there's also
in the club though that like love a nice
hallway
that's like these neon lights that like
light up and make a noise
oh with the dual sensors it's so cool
and then yeah the dual sense also like
vibrates like god it's just the best
video game hallway ever that's the one
the
game of the year award we don't have the
best hallway and it's seafood it's so
sick
is that like the action sequence as well
where the camera goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was very it really does just
make you like like
ins instinctively like wild like it
feels like almost like the
the
kind of like what young was saying
before where it's like okay do that okay
then i do that then i do that it almost
felt like the fight scene from the
robert downey jr sherlock holmes but
like this is fast
okay do that okay do that okay do that
and then die and then do it 70 more
times especially in that club because i
think the club was kind of like how
certain games like a souls like will
give you a thing at the start to make
you kind of
overcome
the game the club is market
the club is absolutely yeah especially
because like at the end it throws stick
lady at you and then right after you
beat stick stick lady good then you have
the two kickboxer guys dick lady is
hotter than sean like i [ __ ] hated
stickley yes but there's one thing about
uh the club in sifu's there's this
blonde chick when you first actually get
into the club that everybody beats up
first yes every time i would always go
straight for her i was like this isn't
anything personal it's just you just
happen to be there but i mean you were
just in the wrong place wrong time i'm
sorry just get slapped about every
single time it's so funny yeah i i
really liked it it's definitely going to
be like one of the game of the year
contenders for me the style really got
me but i also just
i'm not a person who really gets
frustrated so something like that that i
just could play through repeatedly and
then you know effectively become an
expert and i just found so rewarding and
it did come in a window of time right
between other things were coming out so
i just like destroyed it was playing it
constantly so
really really really enjoyed it
after that
horizon was it horizon horizon was
before all the night it was like a rough
season horizon came out very close it
was horizon yeah and i think elder ring
codes went out before horizon codes did
but it was verizon i think no i remember
reviewing horizon before uh no it was
definitely yeah it was horizon okay
first then elden rings some people got
elden ring like three weeks early though
oh well that would have been that would
have been nice guys fantastic
shut up jake
it didn't help at all
um
so horizon i have not played a ton of it
uh but my first impressions were my god
this is beautiful like i was shocked by
how beautiful it was the visual fidelity
and art style of it is incredible on a
level yeah it's it's on a
on another level
it's just a bummer for gorilla that once
again they came in
they keep getting overshadowed and
they don't deserve that uh because they
you can tell how much love and care they
put into this and beyond the fidelity
it's just like the the animations are so
good in this game uh facial wise i mean
it all looked kind of plasticky and zero
dawn i remember it it just all felt kind
of manikinish but here it's like it they
all feel very human um and in the way
just little like they motion capture a
lot of stuff from what i understand and
it shows and it just goes a long way in
sort of the cinematic elements of the
game uh like the
typically in a video game when you have
the back and forth you know where you're
talking to an npc and choosing your
dialogue options it's very stilted it's
like cut here cut here cut back and then
the characters are very still and you
know staring you know straight ahead and
like not doing much but here it's like
the characters are like moving around
they have like ticks and gestures and uh
unique behaviors that are you know part
of what the actors performed that's kind
of all shown through the visuals and it
just makes the characters feel so much
more alive makes them look so much more
natural um and just incredible
across the board the performances
are are they nailed it um my new show
like aloy sweating when she's in you
know the hotter regions versus you know
or she'll be shivering when she's in the
colder regions like so many minutiaes
that just sell you on
uh
the little things and the big things
it's also the draw distance like i was
just blown away by it graphically like
it's just so so so beautiful like the
swimming stuff i really liked as well i
thought that was so neat and like just
so colorful yeah it was it was always
amazing achievement
it's a good video game swimming it's not
yeah i mean it's a massive achievement
regretted yeah whenever any video game
does anything underwater world you're
like
that's a good job man well done like
that is so rare you didn't hate it one
hand all right you can count on one hand
the number of games that have not [ __ ]
that up you know what i mean it's true
got that right so we had a few issues
with swimming like it wasn't like
horrible or unwieldy but there were a
few moments where the swimming would
just like i'd have to like go in this
channel i get stuck and the camera would
go crazy like there were few i did
i had those i had moments but nothing
like game breaking or you know
experience metal gear solid too
nothing else
right uh ralph did you play the whole
thing um yup any more thoughts
absolutely loved it i was so blown away
i mean i actually because i came to the
first one late i like didn't play it at
launch because it was the same thing
came out and then i was like oh breath
of the wild breath of the wild right
let's do that instead and then i just
never came back to my plan is to go back
to forbidden west right yeah yeah yeah
um
when you're done with eldon ring like
six years later it's already been a
month dude
so
um yeah so basically then i played the
pc version of horizon i'm like holy [ __ ]
this is incredible it was i think quite
flawed in regard to sort of open world
stuff and also like its crafting economy
and all the looting [ __ ] and
whatever else probably especially if you
played it late
uh in what way what do you mean like it
may have been dated versus other oh okay
yeah
yeah
i think that that that formula or that
genre does date really fast like i wish
i could say morrowind still holds up
perfectly but it doesn't it does don't
you dare say that anyway yeah um
so
yeah so then obviously winning going
into number two i was really kind of
just expecting a prettier version of
number one but i think in
almost every single metric they took
massive steps up and uh i just was just
awestruck by the end of it i'm like this
is just it's such a great
schlocky
blockbuster kind of aaa game and i and i
liken it to something like avatar right
but i know everyone loves to [ __ ] on
avatar okay i get it fair enough we all
make jokes about avatar that's a pretty
damn impressive product like think about
it man sit back and just like watch this
film and be like it's pretty damn cool
you know on multiplayer
is good yeah yeah i mean like
advertising i was expecting this evening
but here we are well you know what i
mean like okay like i totally get it's
funny to make fun of avatar i make fun
of avatar and there are like four more
movies come out so we are all obliged to
make fun of avatar okay but the point is
that like as a triple a spectacle as a
blockbuster spectacle that is incredible
on many levels and i think this is the
same sort of thing um
i think its biggest accomplishment
really only became evident when elden
ring arrived because
i think it is a brilliant open world
and brilliant open world design but it
is in absolute stark contrast to
everything elden ring and everyone's
holding up elden ring as being like the
perfect open world game and it's kind of
like well it's a really good one i love
it of course but at the same time it
should i think horizon forbidden west if
you put a screenshot of the two of them
next to each other one of them has just
a lot more density than the other one
just a lot more [ __ ] in it like
horizon's just so full of stuff and and
it's so technically again i also love
elden ring i know we all want to talk
about it i'm trying to keep it to the
end we'll gush about it but
like verizon's just just like even the
leaves like there's just so much and it
runs so well
yes my my point that was more about just
the design of that open world and there
is more than one way to design a good
open world you know in terms of the kind
of
stuff that you have in it and how those
how those things work how you manage
your map and so um yeah i think that it
was interesting that eldon ring came out
so soon after that and provided that
sort of contrast um because i think that
the success of horizon forbidden west i
don't think was diminished by alden ring
i actually think it was
elevated by it because i think it
provided a contrast that really
highlighted well there's there's more
than one way to skin a cat you know and
uh very few games have done that open
world design thing better than horizon
forbidden west have in my view what uh
what like specifics are you touching on
what's because i just feel like i really
didn't know what each map like obviously
there's map markers there for sure but
when i get to them i really have no idea
what they're going to be you know what i
mean like
when it's a it's like an exploration
puzzle thing well what is that exactly
am i going underground is it a climbing
puzzle focused thing am i trying to find
a specific item or am i speaking to a
person like it really does feel you're
just pushing forward into these areas
and you're kind of discovering what you
find when you get there you know
um so i really love that but i also
think as well the dynamism of the combat
just made it so good because
as you were moving through it you were
always going through these combat
encounters and i personally feel like
you know obviously elder ring
complicates this discussion but before
eldon ring i would have said that
horizon forbidden west has the best
combat of any open world video game i've
played um the spectacle of facing off
against those like robot dinosaurs and
what you're capable of as a character it
looks pretty it looks like pre-scripted
encounters sometimes if you slow it down
and watch it again you're like how is
that how did i do all that do you know
what i mean it just it's so beautifully
framed and the ferocity of your of your
enemies and your own capabilities i just
i loved it so much i never got tired of
that either so um
yeah and then elder ring comes along
it's like hey how about you i don't know
not yet another
okay
jake did you play horizon
yeah uh i actually i i wasn't
i wasn't in love with the combat it just
kind of felt like the part of the game
that i i had to play
where
i i don't i can't really explain why uh
like skill up in his video like he was
so eloquent about why he thought combat
was the best ever i was like i'm like i
don't know it's too it's too rolly and i
wish it was monster hunter
but i think it gets better as you go you
get more empowered especially once you
go it's like the first one too once you
head into a battle
at least knowing what you need to get
out of it that makes it more fulfilling
but
i it didn't jive with me enough what
kept me going was the look of the world
the exploration i like the world that
they built more here than in the
original just in terms of like towns
civilizations hidden stuff like all that
hit with me so much more than any of the
big city or hub areas or anything like
that in the first one it just felt a
little bit more
i don't know like
they all just meshed better all the
cultures and every all the npcs and
stuff i thought just meshed better with
the world they didn't just feel like
these like people just kind of stand in
there with giant headdresses
it all it all just felt a little bit
more natural and then when you tie that
in
with how
everybody was amazing looking and
everybody's engaging and interesting it
made me want to go explore more just to
like meet more people as corny as that
sounds because i feel like every person
in the game
that you meet
you see how they're modeled and how
they're animated and they're played by
an incredible actor and you're like oh
this guy's cool he's going to be around
for a while look how good the graphics
are yeah yeah and he's like all right
have a nice day i just did i just opened
the door and you never see him again
it's like holy [ __ ] this game is wild it
is interesting to think about how
different some of the open world npcs
are between these three games if we go
dying light too i feel like they tried
to make them like really wacky and weird
and like they're very fallouty or
obsidian style to me
um and then
you go elden ring and they're from soft
npcs so everything is the maidens have
found a sighted race
and then horizon in the middle i feel
like they probably have the most
realistic characters of that group um
and it's three just such different
styles of open world npcs to come out in
a really similar chunk of time it's like
hey maybe video games can be varied cool
yeah yeah how cool was catalog was he
everyone else's boy
anyone else catalog yeah bigfoot
yeah it's just just some saturday man i
don't know i liked a lot of them my the
only thing that i don't love about um
horizon and and i have this issue with a
lot of games um something that eldon
ring very rarely does thankfully
is i just don't love anything that's
like gameplay cutscene
a little bit of walking cutscene um i
have that issue with psychonauts too
like really let that game down for me a
bit um
like i still love both of those games
but i just just something about that
gameplay loop i just find really
frustrating like if i had an opportunity
to
still be engaging in gameplay when
having these conversations i would much
prefer that than having the camera
taking all the control taken away from
me so frequently and horizon does it
enough that both of those games didn't
enough that it bothered me horizon also
has a lot of these missions were
it's like follow the purple trail um
like ghost of sushma also had plenty of
those and like i'm so sick and tired of
that specific mission structure and
horizon did it enough where i i kind of
got disengaged with a lot of quests
because so much of involved just like
follow the thing and listen to ayloy
talk to herself for like uh i like
totally talk so much
right
you know
she kept solving the puzzles i do not
agree with donald trump
[Laughter]
um yeah she kept solving the puzzles for
me and yeah i i was almost like racing
to solve it before she
says anything i was like oh i see the
thing and she'd be like
there's the thing i should use my hook
to like pull it and i'm like [ __ ] like i
know i know i was going to do it just
like let me do it maybe the game thought
you were too slow
they put them in because they were like
this dummy's not going to figure this
out but it's it's not like
after a minute it was literally five
seconds after i this room where the
puzzle is at you'd be like oh there's a
thing that i need to do the thing with
and i'm like well there goes all my
engagement with this section of now i'm
just following instructions and not like
playing the game i can't even imagine
how much dialogue they actually had to
record there is so much of it and i i
think is so well fleshed out like
considering some of the criticisms for
how often she speaks is like i just feel
like she's like such a well-rounded and
i really like her as a character but
it's like it's impressive that you
managed to stay consistent in my opinion
considering how long you spend with her
her performance uh by ashley garcia i
think was really well done uh but
for me actually the the character
development of velo is one of the issues
i had with the gamer she does eventually
like the whole journey with her is like
i need to do this alone and then by then
she's like oh you know it's better with
friends like you know
friendship is you know magic or whatever
but
all right
um but it's just um
i didn't feel like they
focused enough on
just that development of her going from
man
like i know what you mean yeah i mean i
actually do actually actually
sorry you want what oh i didn't finish
it so i don't have a whole whole look at
yeah i actually have similar thoughts on
that i really feel like her narrative
arc in the first game was fantastic
because you've got a situation where
she's coming up she's got something to
prove she's she's now oh she's got this
burden and she is losing to everything
yeah yeah like her most her journey
reflected the game's journey i think and
i think that's actually it's a common
trope across a lot of media i think sony
games in particular really understand
this the way that a personal journey an
inner journey is is mirrored in the
outer journey but i don't think that
horizon forbidden west now that in quite
the same way i don't know i agree loi's
journey possible i got tricked by how
good ashley burch is
yeah
yeah that's easy to be tricked by that
obviously i mean i just played tiny tina
and i'm like how is this the same person
this does not make sense that is
impossible
um but i i'm with you on that young i do
agree with you that that part was just a
little bit i think significantly weaker
than the first game yeah and i feel like
eloy throughout her this whole journey
she always felt like she was so annoyed
by for being surrounded by people yes
she's generally she's always like
like um and
it makes it feel like
the companionship is more of an
obligation than her actually like
developing to like learn to be like you
know what this is actually
better and i need to learn to trust
people and like there aren't critical
moments where she goes
okay that like if i would have done this
alone i i would have failed and there
would have been consequences and like
like moments that really reinforced to
her
that uh there's nothing wrong with
asking for help um it just felt like it
kind of happened is people kept like
annoying aylor and be like look i'm
going to join you i don't care if you
want me to join you're not i'm going to
go along she's like fine all right come
along i did love how they did the
tutorial though the tutorialization was
aloy teaching somebody else i was like
yeah
yeah yeah the whole sequel she should
know everything already obviously
and then with the giant
yeah boss battle there at the end with a
big snake and yeah the mech design i
love
i mean uh i mean i got this guy right
here metal gear wraps but um
yeah the
in terms of combat i i agree that when
you look at it it's it looks spectacular
it looks like like a
a
a pre-made cutscene or something
sometimes with how it's just spectacular
yeah on that look
feel of combat is where i had an issue
that's where i agree more with jake
something about the way it feels um the
fact that you can only dodge and there
was no blocking mechanics or anything
just i really wanted to block sometimes
so um and then
combined with the
management of the weapon wheel and the
so many ammo types and not being able to
really use all the tools that you have
because the weapon wheel is so limited
meant that i i felt like i was not ever
fully
utilizing my creative drive in combat it
felt like i had to just limit myself to
oh well that thing's you know weak to
these elements and only have these
specific weapons that have these
elements i want to use the traps but
it's like these traps just don't happen
to work with this particular encounter
so i'll just shoot it to death because
that's just the best route with the
combat capabilities
yeah so it's like if i i wish it was a
way to just have all my tools available
and then change the ammo stuff on the
fly so that i could just focus on like
the creativity of combat instead of the
managing of combat i i yeah i do agree
with that in part i think that one of
the criticisms i would have of the
combat in this game versus the last
they've added some stuff that just
seemed like needless complexity you know
if they do have some more weapon types
and there are more ammo types and more
systems and all this stuff well it's a
lot of weapons and a lot of different
things that you're like well did you
really need
five or six different types of ammo or
dealing damage when they all ultimately
do the same thing exactly you know and
it's kind of like if you stripped out a
lot of that complexity and just focused
on you know like for example monster
hunter does that really well it's
incredibly deep but it's not i wouldn't
say its core combat is um overly
convoluted do you know what i mean yes
you know it is about your core combos
and it's about the movement of the enemy
and yourself and your locomotion and the
sheath and unsheathing yes i think if it
focused more on that rather than hey you
can now deal damage over time through a
pink
damage type as opposed to a red one it's
like oh cool thanks i think that was it
from being like a satisfying choice then
so like if it if the idea is there are
too many what like where is the line
between satisfying amount of variety and
customization view as a player versus
this feels too complex like where is
that line
i mean for me personally i think it's
i've seen it in other games where it's
kind of that like it's the eminem
it's the equivalent of like choosing
different colored m ms right
when i'm dealing damage over time
not at all like i mean dealing damage
over time with fire versus dealing
damage over time with it's not damage
over time but there's like this pink
element thing in horizon that yeah kind
of deals explosive damage or whatever
does it feel fundamentally different not
really so now i'm just going through
this extra clutter without really
expanding the moment-to-moment gameplay
so um that's where i sort of draw the
line when it comes to that um unless the
customization is changing the way i
actually play then i then i'm not a huge
fan of it make sense yeah i i felt like
you know oftentimes enemies have these
like little barrels sticking out and
they're different colors based on the
element you should strike them with so
they blow up and cause a chain reaction
and it just felt like oh i need to find
the right color for the right canister
instead of like oh this thing has this
effect and this has this other effect
how do i use these very different
effects creatively and like style on
these enemies it didn't feel quite that
it just felt like i was managing
colors and ammos based on the colors
um yeah i agree that the effects weren't
stark enough in contrast for me to feel
like i could employ them creatively just
felt like i was
kind of doing what the game was telling
me to do which is like okay use this
color for that color and use this yeah
for that color
so i mean i ended up i ended up just
kind of limiting myself to a few options
that's what i think i usually do yeah i
just don't
you trip caster and your bow and some
explosives like firebomb whatever yeah
but and i think when you start to narrow
in on that stuff that's when i was just
like this is so good because again that
enemy design
just the variety of it the way they
behave i just couldn't get enough of it
i would i would just i never mounted up
when i played that game like i just
didn't mount to because i was like i'm
always just gonna walk wherever i go
because i'm gonna find something
interesting to do and i'm gonna find
something cool to fight and that was
always it and i think that was just the
secret to its formula you know fine
interesting stuff or kill interesting
stuff all the way through you know
the stuff there is to kill like the the
the animations of the the mechs
themselves like yes yeah it's ridiculous
how much detail and the unpredictability
of them the unpredictability the the
attacks them their move sets it's all it
all feels like
big ass like monster hunter or dark
souls boss sequences
like some of them are just normal combat
sequences that aren't about in the open
world yeah and they can feel so epic so
that's awesome
um well i think next is elden ring
oh my god am i right
and yeah how long do we have
i held it off for as long as i could
um
[Music]
so then eldon ring came out and this is
like the longest i think i've ever seen
video game discourse stay on one game
like it's been over a month i don't even
feel like breath of the wild was was
this long everybody's still just talking
about it uh yeah so
do you want to go first how'd you feel
about that
yeah that what what breath of the wild
was like the pinnacle of open world
design for me back then me too then
alden ring came along
and what eldon ring does is
when i discover something i don't find a
korok seed i don't know what i'll find
i i i don't know what like the catacombs
you know that's
i'd say the most formulaic thing there
is in the game or like yeah these are
dark souls heating elements yeah but
even then like the boss at the end you
don't know what you'll really find what
rewards will you find what talisman will
suddenly change up the your entire
conception of your character build um
what freaking like when i found that
freaking elevator that led me
like a million feet underground and then
this whole other
my god like i i
and and then i checked my map and turns
out i can find map fragments for this
underground like i i that's when i began
to realize i don't have enough time to
finish this game a week are you kidding
me yeah i think a lot of reviewers
didn't finish it because it's just so
big yeah only i think i at least i don't
know who else i know
did yeah salzman but i don't know any
others that finished it on the embargo i
could be wrong about that i'm sure that
i'm sure they were in fact i also don't
know of mitch that do you feel like you
need to for eld and read no no um which
is not something i would often say i
never i never reviewed a game without
finishing it but in this case it's like
you do know what it is
50 hours in you do know what it is
it's not like you need to finish the
story and find out what the [ __ ] the
elden ring is
you're okay i think the friends we made
along the way well it's also that you
can like make your review worse by
trying to crunch too hard and then you
have another impression it's like this
whole thing to balance but yeah yeah i
mean i think fromsoft has always been
really good at that like you turn around
a corner and you don't know what's going
to be there and i've always felt like
that's one of the things they're best at
and i was actually worried about elden
ring i was like i don't know if they're
going to be able to pull off that
surprise which is again one of my
favorite things about their games of
like me walking in a corridor in this
planned sequence and there's a giant
snake and i'm like ah but they nailed it
like the fact that they did manage to do
it in an
open world it's like i don't even know
how i don't know how they did it you're
never taken out out of gameplay it all
happens organically as you're walking
around
crazy [ __ ] will happen around you crazy
creatures will show up and
this is
no loading screens this is no loading
screens um performance issues aside i
had really really bad performance issues
you did okay right really really bad
like i just bought it on console because
i'm still having such bad frame rate
drops on pc
uh that
like after 40 plus hours i
got sick of it um so i want console out
which is a huge bummer also i think the
network issues suck and i still think
the ui is not great and we just give
them such a pass for it
um but
incredible video game
it's
yeah i want to say top three favorite
games of all time uh it it's there's i
haven't felt
about a video game like this um since
like ocarina of time when i that that
first time you realize oh video games
can do this and they can bring me these
kinds of emotions like the thing that's
nuts about that is the amount of people
who feel that way it's like
it feels like it was personally tailored
for you to have this incredible
experience again i felt this way about
breath of the wild as well and then you
play this and you feel that way where
you just constantly are in this
feeling of all
uh but then so does everyone else you
know like yeah yeah the fact that it's
so that formula is so applicable to so
many people is just nuts yeah i uh i
tend to get tired of a game after the
100 hour mark with breath of the wild i
got to like 130 and then i was done
persona 5 i got to like one
120 hours ish elden ring i've played now
for close to 200 hours i still haven't
started new game plus because i'm still
finding [ __ ] i'm just like i i i roll
credits and then i explore the open
world turned out there were entire major
bosses that i missed entire like an
entire underground section that i just
didn't know how to get to before and
that i suddenly stumbled upon um i
started like sifting through the map now
now that i'm like all right i'm probably
not going to find anything else by
myself let's see what else is out there
based on the wiki guide
and there's still some [ __ ] that i'm
like
i can't believe there's still more to
offer and that's a big game
it's huge it feels like six years were
used incredibly well in this game's
development
and um
i don't know to me this is i'm this
isn't the only way to make an open world
but i was getting really
just tired i think maybe that partially
contributed to my not being like
blown away by horizon forbidden west it
still felt somewhat formulaic the best
version of that formulaic kind of open
world style but eldon ring was such a
breath of fresh air maybe that's partly
why so many people are drawn to it
um and it's not like the only way to do
open world design but it's
i'm a very big fan of not cluttering my
mini-map like and it just everybody
seems to feel that way yeah it's so odd
that it's so consistent i think it's
like
maybe it does well in play testing um
yeah
probably for like you know a lot of
people need a lot of direction and it's
more helpful for more people but i love
like the map markers i thought that was
a really good thing in the patch has
given me more map markers is really
helpful i use them all the time like i
saw some tweets saying have a notebook i
didn't do that but i don't fundamentally
i disagree with that like i feel like
that's not a bad idea
um
yeah the just never need a mini map
markup
set of checklists ever again in my life
like assassin's creed just burned me out
on that too badly yeah yeah i i felt
like it like it actually like we talked
so much about like
organic exploration and exploration
happening organically but this is the
first one where it felt like it it
really did you know like because ubisoft
games have tried to kind of tweak that
formula i remember far cry 5 was big
because they they did do stuff where it
was like you could just find an npc and
he'd be like there's a there's a tower
over there i heard and then all of a
sudden it would be on your map and then
you go okay maybe that's a tower over
there like so they they they tried but
it never actually still felt organic
because it still felt like you were just
populating your map yeah where
elden ring i think is kind of like the
antithesis of just like stumbling upon
things and i tried to like we were
talking about how
massive it is i tried to make sure i was
like okay like but like
if i distill it down to not a million
hours and not having so much content to
always stumble upon
is it still good because you know like
not every development studio is going to
be able to make a massive world packed
with that many things i'm like is it
still good in its raw
form and yeah essentially it is because
it has it has a souls formula and it's a
it's a very good one and the jump button
is very good every 15 minutes like you
could give somebody that game anywhere
15-minute chunk have at it they're all
going to have a very exciting unique
experience no matter where you put them
on the map as long as you haven't killed
everything you'd be like just try it out
see what happens and i feel like
everyone is going to be like whoa what
like because there's no lull i feel like
the
the open world isn't as populated uh or
again as dense as as horizon it probably
is more similar to breath of the wild
which wasn't also wasn't super populated
no yeah but this and there's just so
much creativity in the different stuff
that you find yeah
i think it's the imagination i think is
something i don't know that we talk
about imagination a lot
but i mean obviously any video game is
the result of imagination but this one
just feels like
it just it just i don't know it feels
like a fever dream
otherworldly yeah yeah it just it just
seems to sort of flow
out as though you've just like
i don't know man you've passed out
somewhere after smoking too much
something and then yeah this is what
this is what happened and you like for
real though like and i just think the
fact that we're able to capture that
is so
rare and so special like that that is
what i take away from it more than
anything else because i do think that
this like many of what it's a lot of
what's done has been done before you
know what i mean i don't think breath of
the wild is that dissimilar in terms of
most of its core design and certainly
stuff like outer wilds which i won't
shut up about but like you know same
thing when it comes to discovery and
exploration but i just think the way
that you're able to apply that
philosophy combine it with the fromsoft
rpg and combat model which has really
been developed over the better part of
two decades and then blow it up over a
six year development cycle with hundreds
of developers and this massive budget
able to create that's that amount of
square mileage and then pack all of that
square mileage with this imagination
like that is
just an incredible combination of stuff
and i and i think oh i'm sure people are
wondering well what can developers take
from this and i don't know man like
what can they take from it like you're
going to tell me some other studio is
going to try and make something like
this i don't know i just i don't know i
don't know about that
i would say like
the map is a thing that i would
want like all games to have almost like
again
the lack of of markers i feel like is so
helpful um
but you're right that like the
imagination the creativity is not
something that can be easily replicated
in that it wouldn't even necessarily
make sense elsewhere it would just be
jarring and weird but again i think
they've always been good at that
it's the difference between walking into
a fort and seeing a guard
which is like every other game and then
in eldon ring you walk into a fort and
you'll see this weird guy wearing like
this helmet with like a plate on top of
it and then it starts [ __ ] spitting
fire everywhere and you're just like
what is happening right now yeah yeah
like
the negative stuff that happens it's
like you know the hugging thing yeah
like even finding that out or that the
guy um just before godric who's stealing
your souls
like you're finding those things out
sorry runes
like even the negative stuff i'm like
[ __ ] what how
they even put negative effects on the
player that are still very exciting to
discover which is like not a lot of
games do that
and the sheer number of options that
this game gives you while i wouldn't say
this makes the game entirely accessible
it makes it far more accessible than
previous
souls games where you can almost like
decide i want to skip this boss come on
chad mimic let's do this and just like
go in there and obliterate an enemy that
by yourself would be much more difficult
or you can cast the you know freaking
kamehameha and just melt an enemy in two
seconds yeah or also obviously very
helpful that co-op of course or if
you're like a traditionalist like i
would pick and choose my battles some
bosses would be like oh this is one of
those and i'm like i gotta like learn
this boss and just find them by myself
because that's what would be most
satisfying to me but if it's too
difficult for some people or they don't
want to like spend that time melt him
away like
there is skill and there's preparation
there's that's the sort of the two
things you can do in souls you can break
the game and part of the fun of elderly
is like learning how to break it almost
and from soft it almost feels like they
encourage that with the sheer number of
like spells combined with the talismans
and the physics that you can drink and
the different effects they have and how
you can combine all these almost
like it's almost like binding of isaac
when you got all these different
upgrades and crazy [ __ ] can happen it
feels like that where your builds can
really break the game and you can either
do it you know fairly or whatever
without cheating the game and yourself
by uh just like learning the boss or you
can just like over prepare and just just
annihilate the boss i think that sucks
play it however you want yeah play it
however you want and do whatever you
want
yeah that's what we need to be able to
that's what i love about elder ring is
like there's so many options to make
your own fun um yeah i'm planning to
now that i bought it on console do a
full magic
run because i have not touched it really
at all i just want strength and decks
because i always do so i am going full
magic
yeah yeah magic
but i was also like for the basically
this is technically the third time i
started the game i was gonna look up
walkthroughs this time which is
something that i've always recommended
for from games yeah
because if you get frustrated it can be
bad enough sometimes that people just
want to give up depending on the kind of
person you are and it i don't think
there's any shame in having a
walkthrough if you feel like you'll
it'll make you enjoy things so what i'm
going to do is just be like
best early
magic armor whatever and then just go
find it and figure it out yeah i think
that's fine you're allowed play it
however you want
and it's as the devs intended or
whatever like miyazaki
when people criticize like whoa you're
summoning mimics for your boss battles
that's not how the debt like they added
the mechanic for a reason dude
why are you upgrading your why are you
attacking an enemy you're not supposed
to do that that just makes the game
easier rolls only yeah
play through i'm saying that whole
discourses i love the options that alden
ring gives you yes i will say again the
only thing that i
like don't love where the options are
concerned is the ui where sometimes i'll
pick something up and be like where is
that yes and what does it do uh okay
turns out you can sort by uh the order
in which the items were acquired i only
learned that yeah you can that's helpful
yeah that's super helpful i only learned
that
but they never tell you that so that's
obviously an issue that's definitely a
ux issue yeah
just it's just a bit of a mess and the
fact that there's like
inventory and equipment i think the fact
that i can't even remember the names of
the individual menus i feel like is also
telling considering the amount of hours
i put in like it's just a bit of a mess
yeah um and they're repeatedly like s is
flasking what i'm trying to get on my
mount
sorry tears like
that definitely is a thing but it's i
think
this has been an interesting thing to
watch game devs talk about on twitter is
people trying to figure out why
the public is forgiving of a lot of the
flaws is i think pretty obvious which is
when the positives you feel so
positively about yeah the flaws just
like go down in importance so
dramatically so quickly that you're like
yeah you can have a flawed video game
nobody's asking for a perfect video game
it doesn't exist the positives just have
to be so positive that you're like the
ui kind of sucks whatever it's fine
exactly yeah the game's good though i
get that all the time in my comment
section like you said this about that
game but you didn't say it about this
one what a double standard it's kind of
like well
no that's not how this works like you
can hit certain thresholds for enjoyment
and when you pass those thresholds then
you forgive certain things and similarly
when you fall below them then those
things become really top of mind because
you're not thinking about how much fun
you're having you're thinking of how
much fun you're not having and you're
looking for stuff to blame and so you
find the [ __ ] [ __ ] you are and you're
like gearbox when are you gonna update
this ui it's been so many years come on
now you know my god so um yeah like it's
just
yeah you we all have different tolerance
based on how much we fall in love with
something else exactly and you know
individual features don't exist in a
vacuum they exist in the context of the
entire game exactly correct
i've also just been digging it as like a
cultural movement because yeah seeing
everybody experience it and a lot of
people it be their first souls game or
their first souls game where they make
substantial progress
like all of that has just been really
satisfying to see especially because
like i usually don't care about the
discourse or anybody but like we were
talking about before because it has been
so large it's like unavoidable and it's
all been pretty good you've seen people
help each other the memes have been
consistently good for what is it a month
now do i still see [ __ ] from eldon like
i still see elden ring memes that make
me laugh and i think that's yeah i think
that's pretty funny and it it's like
it's a good it's just a it's just a good
whole
gaming experience especially just you
know i don't know helping one another
and learning the game
when i was playing through the first
dark souls when it came out i was on
like a facebook group
and everyone back when
people used facebook and everyone's just
figuring out things in real time i had
the same experience as breath of the
wild but i feel like on with elden ring
it's just on such a large scale right
now that it seems like it's everyone you
know and i'm already like i don't want
to use twitter right now because
everyone's talking about the [ __ ]
oscars which i don't care about right
i'm gonna stay off for three days why
what happened give me my eldering back
nothing
else
shut up so it is it is really fun to
experience
something like this like with the
community for sure and i'm so glad it's
done so well like i
i didn't think people who don't like
from soft games
would like this game and i still still
think that applies like to an extent
like if you don't like the formula you
don't like the combat you don't like the
rolling and you don't like the ui i
don't think this is the game that's
gonna change that uh it does seem like
people have been a little bit split on
whether it's
more don't want to say accessible
because that's the wrong word but easy
to get into yeah um for some people it
definitely is like because you can leave
and and go grind somewhere else and then
come back but then i know some people it
kind of depends on the person
who haven't liked it as much because it
feels directionless like they just don't
feel like they have anywhere
specifically to go and and you know that
there's always variety in that but it
seems like like by and large people love
it and it's fun it's nice when people
like something especially in video games
yeah but it's even to the point where
we're seeing people so the fact that
like what did it sell like over like 12
million copies like it's unprecedented
how many people dark souls lifetime 13
million
yeah like the whole million trilogy two
cultures the whole trilogy
yeah but no i think it's i think it's
something it was the figure was
something like it took the entire dark
souls trilogy
x number of years to hit 12 million
and then
no and then eldon ring hit 12 million
units
you know like it's a totally different
and that part is utterly staggering to
me i never in a billion years would have
guessed this like absolutely not i
really thought we were just in in for
dark souls 4 level of engagement yeah
you know hey
from fans will love this and it will
sell well and hey pc sales are higher
this time around what a surprise still
top of the charts i think it was i
looked on steam yesterday it was the
number two game being played on steam at
that moment when i was watching it right
after cs go i believe
um yeah that makes sense so i mean that
is
a single player
from soft game a
super hardcore rpg
being played like that number two most
played game on steam
said the trilogy was 27 million
apparently yeah yeah but like i was
saying it was like as i said
dark souls has sold more but the time at
which it took to reach 12 million units
or something was way longer than a week
nothing but happening
10 million yes lifetime or something um
so it in two weeks it surpassed it and
it'll probably keep going
keep going yeah i'd be surprised if this
game doesn't sell at least 20 million i
wonder what the completion rate is right
now like it can't be questionable like
it must be
no like four like four percent yeah i
mean it's gonna like in that yeah
there have been impressive stats i saw a
couple weeks ago it was it was of the
the amount of people i think playing on
pc
that were able to pass
god uh it was margin and godric and it
was a it was a pretty respectable amount
and i was very happy for like people
jumping into this game for the first
time and just going i don't know it got
good reviews like
the numbers were pretty good that people
were actually overcoming that and that's
like a really impressive first obstacle
i'm not trying to like belittle people
but like that's no it's sick yeah i mean
sure the the concurrent numbers it's not
like the be all and all of all data but
it does tell you some information and
like those numbers have stayed
consistently in like the 500 000 at
least or above uh in the first week or
two like it actually went up the the
high the peak and current player 750 000
to 800 than 900 000. and it's like it
just continues and now still like over
500 000 people still play the game so
it's like it's hitting always happy to
see it because it's like okay this means
that like every
publicly traded publisher can can go
this game doesn't have microtransactions
look at what they did with their map
look how well it's doing and they can
just yeah but that's just that those
conversations have been happening with
developers forever probably just i know
that conversations about cyberpunk have
made it to people who
matter uh like at dev studios the
conversations about cyberpunk being like
this game shipped broken look how upset
people were we are not shipping broken
like has actually happened you're like
okay well maybe every time that
something comes out that's not great and
it actually has a huge impact that's
technically good for everything else
in theory uh but i feel that way every
time resident evil sells well i'm like
give me more
survival horror games come on they keep
selling yeah i hope i hope it tells
developers more more spooky creepy games
yeah not horror games but just games
that are just weird and spooky like
there's a there's a horror girl there's
a haunted ghoul man yeah go talk to them
like just put more of those in games
yeah yeah more weird stuff more weird
stuff yeah i mean in theory they could
just say it's the rolling
like everybody got a roll one thing that
i still haven't been able to do very
well in uh elden ring to the extent that
i'm barely even doing it is is the
parrying
um
sure i'm just dog [ __ ] at it like and i
think it's because the timing is always
a little bit i have to do it a little
bit earlier than i think yeah but it's
almost through the game's credit that
it's like the animations
yeah yeah and he does a whole thing so
it's like you have to like see where the
animation lands and time it based on
that and like in my head i'm like i know
that i should just
burn a few deaths and go and just figure
it out but i don't want to die so i just
keep not practicing dodging still a good
option yes just dodging i'm cool with it
yeah
is there anything else that we have not
covered that anyone would like to say
about eldon ring
i would just like to say fever i think
ralph said fever dream
and uh that's what it felt like you know
mainlining that game for a couple of
weeks
especially how by the second half of it
it goes full buck wild where i was
worried i'm like are they gonna go like
really weird like they usually do in
their games where by the end you're
fighting like a puddle of mud or
whatever
and they they definitely oh yeah but i
was really happy about that
yeah
again i think they've always been good
at that one thing that i don't think
they get enough credit for is um
their bosses this time like not only are
they always so creatively designed and i
don't mean the fights i mean the way
they look
so well animated because they went
straight from playing dark souls 3 to
eldon ring and just the upgrade in
animation is tremendous like everyone's
so well animated it's so cool they're
also their physics are really good like
there's a lot of stuff that like we give
them credit for a million things but
there's some things that they're just so
so so good at considering how difficult
it is to make something that has five
heads
and then they have so much enemy variety
like that's a whole person's job for six
years is making those bosses function
the way that they do and they're so
there's 85 of them or some [ __ ] to get
the platinum yeah
even even the ones that repeat what i
love is that when you fight him again
you'll have a new move next time or uh
like
even the repeat bosses feel fresh when
you fight him again it's yeah it's
incredible it's rare that you play a
game that just feels impossible
and i don't mean impossible to complete
but i mean it's possible to exist like
how did this how does this exist in this
way because
you could
do your thesis on it you could spend the
next five years of your life studying
this thing and how it was constructed
and how it works and you still wouldn't
get it all you know what i mean because
it is just such a remarkable creation i
think
um and it's very rare that you can say
that of any game yeah uh this game
i've played close to 200 hours and it's
still got my attention like i still want
to go back to it and that like i don't
know if i'm just getting old that for me
is very rare
i
again like at the one to 100 to 120 hour
mark i'm like usually done with a game
with ellen ring i'm excited for my next
build i'm already thinking like i got
all these
tools and weapons that i've collected
throughout my adventure that's just
fodder for me to be able to play with
for my next one where i can just like
mess around and then you can like
respect super easily in this game so i
can like work on multiple like
cycle between multiple builds and i'm
excited just like experiments still
and
no game really in recent memory has done
that for me so this is and again so many
people feel that way that's incredible
like it's not exactly i had this period
early on where i was just taking
screenshots of the map and then putting
a little x and then sending it to people
being like have you been here
we got we got one of those from you yeah
yeah i did
that's another aspect i love about this
game is it feels so communal um it feels
so much like we are all together in this
like figuring it out together like
there's there was an instance where like
a friend of mine we were playing it
together and uh my friend figured out
how to get to this underground section
but he was earlier in the game than i
was because i managed to play the review
copy and i didn't know about that that
thing existed so i went there but
there's a quest that i could trigger
that he couldn't because i was later in
the game and i had the right thing to
give to the npc to continue the quest
line that he wouldn't have known about
if he wouldn't have gotten that
information from me who went into that
area late so like it's like different
people finding [ __ ] out for a long time
yeah yeah um like we you know i we make
fun of the whole like this is a strand
type game meme but i feel like this is a
strand type game i'm gonna say that's
gonna put it on every game
like it's right it's just um one of the
things you missed out during the review
processes is that the messages that are
strewn about and that tell you like
there's an invisible wall right there an
invisible floor or an illusory wall or
an illusory floor
and that's
99 like 90 of them are you know trolls
but the 10 that are not
like it's it's a revelation you're like
holy [ __ ] there's something back here
thank you
i still got some of those messages in
the review period yeah i actually found
it in the review period
we're putting down fake wall notes on
the ground and it's like dude
you have who do you work for in advance
you are playing this on a tight deadline
and yet you set aside time on your
[ __ ] schedule to put a fake wall note
on the ground like don't you waste my
time
growing
up i found most of it pretty helpful
during the review period and then when
it came out publicly it was like tanked
so fast yeah impossible
i love the oh you don't have the right
you don't have the right like good god i
love it i still love it i just love that
every time i see it i'm like a praise
yeah
uh jake i think you're gonna say
something and we'll just cut you off
there oh yes oh i i was just gonna say
uh to in terms of like things
other games should take from it is the
the map thing how it just keeps oh oh
boy it gets bigger and then it reveals
itself later on to get bigger and then
80 hours in it reveals itself again to
get bigger it feels like the complete
opposite of a normal game that you buy
and then you
press pause and see the map and you go
oh geez yeah you'd be overwhelmed
yes
that gradual discovery is something that
i would love
yeah i think it makes a hell of a
difference i would love to see more
games embrace that yeah a lot of games
like they give you they kind of show you
the whole map it's all fogged out in
elegant it's like it's the map's like
zoomed in and as you can see
it zooms out and out and out
so you never know how big the world
actually is until you get all the map
fragments and it's enormous i really
thought i knew and then the whole north
section
on multiple occasions like okay so this
is how big this game is oh no
i'm not even scratching the surface
goddamn yeah i just feel like like it's
just giving players a sense of discovery
constantly is like so engaging because
it really does feel like the story is
happening for you and it's something
that i think more studios should lean
into when given the opportunity yeah
it's
very good job of that that's how you
take advantage of the interactive nature
of video games it's like it's about both
the the journey you're trying to convey
but also like the player's own journey
and
what they take from it that's going to
be different from what other different
people take from them we're not taking
the story i don't care what you say
okay
yeah and i don't need it though it's
fine i'll watch a 40 minute youtube
video if i have to
yeah exactly you'll watch yeah we'll
take care of us yeah it's all funny yeah
yeah
that's it it's
the only other thing i think it needs is
uh horse armor dlc i was gonna say i
really feel like the game would have
been stronger if we could purchase runes
at an in-game store yeah
that would have really made the
experience a lot better i would have
liked different mounts
that would have been cool yeah the
donkey is a bit late
i think tauren's kind of badass that's
unbelievable just about like tauren i
appreciate it so he's such a good boy
you think about what you put him through
and he just does it uncomplainingly and
now you can bust out with that
i laugh every time that there's a jump
that's like
like the empire
like building tall like the jumps are so
high it's like you don't because you
don't know how tall it's gonna be when
you take it
my broken brain my broken video game
brain is like so accustomed to like
things always changing and things always
getting better i had convinced myself
playing the game i'm like oh wait he has
more bags on his saddlebag oh he must be
getting stronger just like me and i
realized it was just 80 hours later and
i was just going insane reviewing this
game no no
i would say actually i don't know we
should move on soon but one thing i
would say is that i
the structure i would have liked just a
tiny
tiny tiny bit more guidance on where i
should go next in certain moments so for
example
i completely skipped caleb like
i didn't know that kayla like i knew it
was their ish but then i thought oh
that's not for me that's i'm gonna get
sent there some at some point later on
so i did everything else and i was
always assuming that there was some
moment where the game was going to send
me to caled and then eventually i was
like clearly the game is not going to
send me to caleb i better go and check
out what's over there then i went over
to kayla and i was just one hitting
everything and i mean no way one hitting
but like for example i the the boss
radon right everyone's like bradan so
hard man blah blah blah blah done man he
just fell over because i was so
overstated at that point and i'm so
disappointed because that's fight is
incredible to look at like unbelievable
yeah and i was like
robbed of that experience not the right
word obviously yeah i got teleported
there from a chest and ended up in a
cave which i think a lot of people said
i had that too but then i kind of said
okay i'm in the wrong place and then i
kind of found my way back but then i
thought there's got to be some point
where i get sent to that and so for that
reason
all of caled was lost to me forever that
sense of discovery that i had in the
rest of the game
it's never terrifying
it's so scary to look at like those
[ __ ] birds and those dogs do the jaw
slam thing and like
i was like because i would fight them
and i'm like these things imagine if i
was the right level for these how how
terrifying these would be yeah because i
also left but i went back because i had
found quests there so it was always in
my internal quest log of well i'll go
back there when i'm at higher level and
so i always wanted to go back there but
but you're right and i also think like
the sights of grace
um
it took me a while to figure out what
they were pointing me towards and i
guess sometimes it's just the nearest
point of interest
but it doesn't winning really should the
next key side of grace basically yeah
it's just to the next side of grace
because maybe then i don't even know
because i know some of them are like
fights
because they're in different directions
yeah yeah
the end of the line
would be towards boss fight uh but even
then like once you kill the boss fight
you get a side of grace from that yeah
so it's technically still guiding you to
that side of grace so it's just kind of
string in the side of grace i'm glad
there are so many there yeah yeah there
are a lot and i do like that but yeah
for me i accidentally skipped raya
lucaria because that you get the hint on
where the key is
but it's something distracting
oh
really you can skip back yeah i went the
wrong way around so there's if you go
through the castle you can keep going
but i just went to the side path with
all the wolves and then ended up in the
lake oh yeah and with the legs yeah
right by him see godric for ages
yeah i didn't see riley for ages and
then i was like one shotting everything
and yeah yeah so like everyone has like
their own journey which is something
that i love about this game
but yeah it can also i get that
sometimes without
more guidance you can like lose out on
certain things other people might yeah
and that's less of a risk now in the age
of guides or whatever for youtube videos
and something but certainly playing
through the review window where there
was no guidance whatsoever anyone else
that is playing through
like completely blind like purposely
avoiding anything else then yeah that is
i think a risk that you know is going to
affect a few people at least scary
god what do you mean scary
like it's just like oh boy what do i do
there's no one yeah i get stuck and hit
a wall who do i talk to yeah i know
every other souls game i played after
their launch this was the first uh
fromsoft game that i played with no
guidance whatsoever and there was like
an anticipation
to that where it's like oh man what am i
getting in myself
what am i getting myself into but it was
it was incredible i don't know i loved
every second of it yeah and obviously
people still have the option to do that
which is nice like you can still go and
completely blind if you want to again i
recommend people play souls games with
souls games with guys yeah
yeah absolutely um
next release i think is steam deck
oh
which i believe that the two gentlemen
at the bottom have
young and i do not um
jake
yeah i do have this other like
portable pc it's one of those
yeah the one x player so i can like kind
of talk about that one x player yeah one
x player uh it's just like chunky kind
of uh steam that runs windows right yeah
it runs windows so it's um yeah it's oh
interesting yeah i've been having a good
time with it actually yeah we can talk
about this
yeah steam decks i think i think is
still going to be the preferred option
but this is not a bad one either but
yeah feel free to talk about steam deck
and share with us yeah jake what are
your uh yeah you you're playing it right
when we started it's good and i have a
similar because i i tested the aya neo
which is another uh windows based type
of thing uh and it now it just feels
like inelegant compared compared to this
i just really
i really like it i had it so i can hold
it up it's so big um
it's a big boy but i really really like
how it actually feels like it's just
it's hard to explain but it's just like
plastic it doesn't feel ultra premium it
doesn't feel like a
like a new samsung phone or an ipad pro
it just feels like a plastic device you
use uh and that makes it helpful i love
that especially because like the
joysticks are good the triggers are all
right the face buttons are okay but the
the joysticks themselves are like
really really impressive they feel like
ripped right out of an xbox controller
and that that that makes a difference
but the thing is the thing is awesome
like i was saying before we went live
it kind of walks a line between being
like consumer product accessible it just
works
and like a busted or like in beta thing
it's like in the middle and i think it's
just enough where
it's fun to tweak just how it is with pc
gaming i mean with pc gaming you're
gonna fiddle with settings and that's
what you're definitely doing here and
not every game runs and the battery life
isn't great and it's got it's getting
updated all the time how is the best it
has
issues uh
it's all over the place uh depends on
the game
same as this two hours four hours like i
i've been playing a lot of arkham knight
on it and that just smokes this thing
um
but
it's still
for the power
and especially using
other devices using gaming laptops and
stuff
it's it's pretty it's still pretty wild
even if it doesn't last that long it
it's it's really something else it has
kind of helped me change up how i play
games because
uh
i like just like sitting at a kitchen
table and playing my game sometimes and
i would do that with my gaming laptop
but it just
sucks so
this is ten times better how heavy is it
that was the thing i was worried about
when they announced it was that it looks
so weighty so like how is it to hold for
a long time
uh it hasn't been so bad uh it's heavier
than a switch yeah
do you think so
i mean well like crazy i think it is by
by way
objectively it is not by much
yeah i like
because you look at the site i would i
would say when i picked it up i was
actually blown away by how light it is
because i look at the size of it and i'm
like this in a way of metric [ __ ]
time i guess that means they did a
really good job of making it like
ergonomic like they balanced it really
well right if you don't know yeah
you oh yeah the the back like the dip
for the grippies like where you can grab
a dip
that makes that that makes such a
difference oh my god it's so comfortable
to hold it's usable like you can see the
game on it yeah the switch has is just
like a consistent sort of rectangular
shape like an iphone or whatever but the
steam deck if you hold it up jake
okay there we go but do you see how i
see i don't know that
they make all the difference in the
world because they fit neatly into like
that's where you're where you hold it
they rest into your palms and i love
holding this thing for that reason and i
just i've always hated holding my switch
where do your pinkies go when you're
holding it because like that's the thing
i had with like long gaming sessions on
the switch is like my pinky's like broke
you hold it that way because i hold the
switch kind of like the pinkies are out
you don't really engage these are not
supporting it yeah exactly yeah
yep so that's not a thing i googled the
weight differences and for some reason
the results were really strange
i got the weight for the steam deck in
ounces
and grams and then i got to wait for the
switch in pounds like i don't know why
google has done this to me
so steam deck is set to weigh
1.47 pounds
and then the switch is 0.66
approximately 0.88 when joy-con
controllers are attached which is a
pretty big difference okay that is a big
difference i guess i was really then but
if it's just compromised by yeah but i
guess i was being surprised by looking
at it and thinking there's a whole this
thing looks heavier yeah this thing
looks really heavy but yeah again like
you pick up an iphone and you're just
like
this thing is super dense and it's a
really heavy item to pick up wow
and you're surprised by its heaviness
but then obviously i think when you pick
up the steam deck you'll be surprised by
how light it is i think it's got to do
with the weight distribution and the
balance yeah that just makes it because
it also feels quite hollow as well like
as in to jake's point it feels plasticky
at the steam that the switch
feels entirely solid all the way through
as you pick it up but this one it's much
larger its chassis is bigger it does
feel like a hollow device you know
obviously it's not but it does feel like
it has a lot more empty space inside
that chassis so um yeah yeah yeah
i
oh i okay so it's a mixed bag in the
sense that i absolutely love it
um i am the more i play it the more i am
not convinced necessarily because you
never know how these things are going to
go but i'm very hopeful that this thing
takes off because yeah
this is just there's no need for the
switch to exist
when i have this thing like obviously to
play nintendo exclusive sure but like i
use i always like to play my indies on a
um on a switch now i've played them on a
steam deck because i get to be in the
steam ecosystem which is vastly better
than the nintendo ecosystem [ __ ]
nintendo uh i like the comfort factor of
i like the comfort factor of it the
screen the tweakable performance
like obviously we talk about emulation
as well which is a really big deal
especially at the moment and only
getting more and more important i think
as companies are showing their hands
with regards to how they plan to manage
this stuff the steam deck handles
emulation like a dream um but also i
like i really like the fact that valve
have its valves machine because valve
are a pretty cool company all things
considered they're really open with
regards to how they approach things
transparent they're like they're happy
for you to have this device and do what
you want with it yeah very useful that's
not how devices work
you can't do anything on this thing that
apple does not specifically condone and
nintendo's the same but even playstation
and xbox is similar but
they have made us a console that we can
treat like an open platform pc and that
in itself is just such a revolutionary
step to have a mainstream console behave
like that from an ecosystem perspective
is such a game changer you know i mean
it literally examples of pc you know
like yeah yeah for sure yeah for sure
which makes it so flexible
a good example of their approach right
is the so it has uh you bring up on the
side like the volume and brightness uh
and then you also have like battery
tracker and battery settings and it's
it's levels where you can crank it up
one two three four and and the regular
battery level is just battery life um
and performance tracker really uh you
you bump it up to one you get a little
frame counter to see your frames per
second you want to get a little nastier
are you a bigger nerd turn it up to two
then you can see frames per second cpu
performance you want to get even wilder
let's see how every core is doing and
turn it up even more track temps like it
it it's valve's like interface way of
showing that
they are making it easy it is a product
but they're still valve and they still
are down to give you the freedom to
tweak it
analyze it mess with it break it be a
nerd about it and
i like that has really made it even more
exciting for me it's giving me like the
childhood thrill again of like when i
used to like hack my ipod and [ __ ] like
that and like try and put doom on
everything it's sold out right like it
completely sold out but yeah that seems
like such a niche
interest that like i feel like isn't
like i wonder how it will sell versus
the switch which you know people like
most people
don't care about
seeing their cpu like majority of people
who buy video games unfortunately are
not big notes like they don't care so i
wonder
how appealing that stuff is
can you play it on a plane airplane mode
well okay yes you can firstly
and i would say as well one really
important point about battery life and i
think
yes obviously you can see performance
metrics but more important than that you
can tweak the performance of the machine
on the fly so you have your in-game
options obviously because it's a pc game
so you can do whatever you like with
those but then you also have options
built into the actual steam ui that
allow you to hard cap it to 30 fps so i
can allow you the question for how that
will appeal to the casuals is like is
that ui super readable is it really easy
to get into they make sense literally a
slider it is literally a slider it's a
bunch of things and then well you can
just ignore it but even but even then i
feel like that discussion about like
casuals and what have you like the pc
gaming market has not ever had interest
not never but like they naturally stay
away from consoles because they're like
well i like what i've got here and i
don't mind tweaking with stuff in fact
that kind of works for me and i don't
think we can say that the pc gaming
market is niche you know like it's it's
huge and it's only getting bigger and
bigger i remember seeing a statistic
about the sales of eldon ring and i
think the highest number of unit cells
was actually on pc correct me if i'm
wrong but like that market is
continuously growing and i think this
could potentially be an even not a big
shot in the arm but another step in that
journey towards mass pc adoption because
you've really got now a pc inside a
console and
that it's a cool thing for people who
don't have pcs it's like definitely
like i hope that you see and it's super
cool for me yeah you know
i'm just coming in from the angle of
like for people who
don't pc game is this a thing that they
will buy because it is still the
smallest market of all of the gaming
i think what makes it so appealing is
the freaking price point i can't believe
they got this down how much power
dollars yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
interesting running at a loss like damn
that's a great question i i would be
surprised if they want to do lost late
on this no i don't think they would it's
just so efficient but it's shocking yeah
yeah really nice wild crazy yeah it's so
the other thing i think people don't
i think people don't unders i think
people don't realize i think how many
people
have a steam library i think like i've
known people out there that like just
like oh i went to college and i use the
macbook but like i would always redeem a
game or every once in a while get a game
or i'd win a game
or i'd buy one so like i feel like a lot
of people are sitting on steam library
sometimes and they couldn't
necessarily take advantage of it totally
on their mac or apple product and they
couldn't go out and buy you know
thousands of dollars or whatever a
thousand dollar gaming pc and then this
comes along and the base level one is
four
four hundred four hundred yes four
hundred it's super impressive four
hundred and six fifty for the
twelve games somebody in chat has tried
to say pc gaming market is the biggest
gaming market by revenue other than
mobile
uh steam that's not 120 million
monthly active users as of 2020. i mean
let's think about us league of legends
for example i don't know like when we
talk about what are we talking about
what are the comparisons we're talking
about here i i don't know i would
suspect that probably is true it does
look like it's closing this so uh most
recent data is pc generated 35 billion
while consoles was 49 billion so right
and then mobile's obviously bigger than
both of them unless we're referring to
kind of different metrics um for some
reason but i think console is yeah
console is consistently bigger than pc
still which i mean that's a primarily pc
game oh like yeah i want to tell you
like super far behind it's you know it's
still huge yeah that steam deck will
have enough of a market to sell pretty
well if you know if it's handled
appropriately i mean i've got a steam
library of a thousand games i don't know
about you guys but like
and then and then it's like and now 200
of those are steam deck verified like
and then a lot of those are also just
playable on my steam deck i buy a steam
deck i immediately have access what is
very thousand games
verified means that it is basically like
they've gone through and confirmed that
it actually works properly on the steam
deck as intended without having to make
major concessions like for example if
text is too small and unreadable that
would not be verified but if they were
to make a patch if they were to issue a
patch that then offers a you know a
steam deck
fix for text sizes it would then become
verified it's a moving feast they're
getting verified all the time things are
moving around but the point is that like
you know already one-fifth of my entire
steam library is playable on that and
it's backwards compatible in perpetuity
nobody's making you buy the games again
exactly thank you very much this is one
of the reasons why i don't want to have
to deal with nintendo anymore do you
know what i mean so yeah i just feel
like all of this stuff just clicks for
me so well and i just love it so much
i'm playing fewer and fewer console
things these days i'm spending more and
more time i'm almost exclusively in the
console uh pc ecosystem now unless i'm
playing a first party exclusive you know
on playstation most days because xbox
now do all this stuff on pc and the
steam deck is what i will use in the
future as my console on the go when i
don't want to be at my desk or i'm in
the house doing something else want to
be on the couch when i'm traveling
somewhere the steam deck is what i will
use and i just think that is so good so
yeah having said that i have had some
problems with it okay my i've had some
technical issues with it can i ask how
the heat is because a few people in chat
ask that does it get hot yeah heat is um
it does get warm but the thermal's
really smart because imagine if this is
the steam deck then oh there it is and
then so there's actually the fan is at
the top and it blows the heat right up
but more importantly
when you are holding it the
handles don't have anything going on
inside them they're essentially empty
plastic except for the haptic motors so
you don't feel any of that heat if you
touch the back of it absolutely you feel
this thing is hot why would you when you
are holding it you never feel any heat
yeah so um they've designed yeah like
the thermals from like lion tech tips or
whatever like it's blue on the handles
and then like red and orange in the
middle yes exactly exactly well done but
i have had problems with my haptics like
in fact a lot of problems like my left
trackpad doesn't have any haptics at all
right
yeah okay right i actually emailed um
valve about this and they said that some
of that might be a bug some of it is
being looked at at the moment in terms
of like there was an update that went
out that my right stick when i move it
it engages the haptics motor even though
it's not meant to do that like the
lipstick doesn't do that but the right
one does
even when i'm just navigating menus and
that's clearly a bug so there's a few
things that they're working through and
so this argument about you know should
you buy a steam deck right now or should
you wait for gen 2
i mean i don't think you're going to
feel ripped off if you buy steam deck
today
because i think it has so much to offer
and it's really cool but at the same
time you do need to accept that it is
gen one it's gonna have some problems
yeah but then obviously with it yeah but
then when you get to that gen two gen
three then i think it's like lock it in
man this is a fantastic [ __ ] purchase
because i think it's an awesome product
yeah gen 2 steam deck i think is going
to be
like the one like it they're already
like close to nailing it it's just like
software a lot of software stuff they
have to fix which you know they'll do
over time
uh hardware wise i feel like for a gen
one product man yeah like they've really
like
nailed the components the performance
the just the right balance of price to
power like it everyone seems really
enthusiastic about it so again it's that
balance of like recognizing that it has
some issues but being forgiven that the
giving of them because the positives
that way the negatives by so much i
guess
it also has the benefit of like to go
back to elden ring it's almost like
playing elden ring six months later and
seeing a whole community
built out already or or a souls game
where people have been playing souls
games and builds for years so
for this it's it's it's like the steam
community and the linux community that
have been like putting in work for years
with controller layouts compatibility
stuff
back end hacks and stuff like to be able
to get epic game store on here like that
it's all linux users and all those
people being like come on in we've been
working and now you can enjoy yourself
we'll help you you can also mod your
games because it's a pc
yeah that is awesome yeah yeah without a
like required marketplace that that is
awesome exactly
so uh yeah
yeah anything else that we should know
about
it good luck getting one lol it's just
not going to be available for like what
18 months i reckon if you would have if
you were to pre-order one now which i
don't even know if you can pre-order
them i don't imagine you're going to get
it it's inside this it's still q3 you
can program it right now is it crazy
they do say they are ramping up
production which is great i know
obviously it's not even out in all
markets like mine was sent to me as a
review unit but it's not out in
australia new zealand a whole bunch of
territories so hopefully they speed that
up as well because um i'm so curious to
see how it sells like i'm just like
yeah is this a thing that i could get my
sister
who doesn't game on pc right now to like
play pc games with me like maybe i think
i'm not
not sure i'm very curious to see how it
yeah
also just for for people and for people
in the chat or people watching uh they
like they give you like a really good
case with this thing it's like yeah it's
like shocking really good yeah
so strong it's like i'm so used to being
like abused as a consumer like intake
and like they gave me something that was
like in it and i'm like oh my god you
guys really love me it's like it's
really nice it's like a legit case like
it's like one i had to go out of my way
and go to three targets to buy a case
for my switch when that came out this
thing is this thing is nice wow when you
knocked on that that was a solid sound
boy look at look show the inside as well
because it's got like the that it's got
like that molded foam yeah the padding
is all like exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah
man we're getting a live unboxing from
uh jake baldino
uh see more of that case that would be
nice
mine's not quite the this is a steam
deck at home oh yeah um but i just got a
switch this is still like very usable
either got great triggers uh that thing
is a beast it's it's huge it's an eight
inch screen um so what is it exactly
clean up a little bit um it's
just a pc okay in this form factor um
it's straight up what what essentially
steam deck except it comes built in with
windows so everything's compatible from
the outset um the drivers and everything
were you know made for it to run on
windows and so you know
there are certain things in steam deck
that i think are still incompatible
because some things just run better on
windows and or just only run on windows
for now i guess but
with this it's like it's all kind of
already it's just windows that's all it
is um
now it doesn't happen
this was
it was it started out as a kickstarter
actually oh cool all right and then it
yeah and then enough people bought i
guess their first iteration for them to
keep making new models is not there's a
mini version that i'd recommend i think
to more people because this one's i
think a little too big it's huge um and
the mini one has better grips but this
has a bit of a grip back here like the
contours there your finger can
grasp on it so it's still like fairly
solid it's still fairly comfortable
especially for holding it more like this
here it's like it gets a little heavy
and it feels like it you have to like
put pressure sort of inwards so it stays
but the buttons feel comfortable the
analog sticks are nice and it's just a
big ass portable windows pc how much is
it um touch screen that's so that there
is the rub that's the the reason steam
deck will dominate the market this is
thirteen hundred dollars holy [ __ ]
it's about it performs about as well as
steamed it has a better cpu than steam
deck but steam deck is based on our dna
two gpu as this is vega and i believe
our dna chooses better so they're i
think steam deck overall is like about
the same or a little better in terms of
just running games
now this has the benefit of a high
resolution screen though i think they
put too much screen on here with a 2600
by 1600 resolution
but
it what what it does enable is like say
you're playing hades which is not super
graphically demanding you can go beyond
12
12 um 1270 by 800 i think is the steam
deck and it just looks a lot sharper
yeah
when you go to 16 by nine or whatever
1600 by 900 and so for
weaker games you can boost up the
resolution and still play at 60 frames
per second comfortably and it just looks
really good on an eight-inch screen
that's like right here so they're big
it's so weird to look at enormous i i
would not it's cool though it's cool how
many people are getting into that market
yeah that one's way better than this one
this is the that looks like a game
yeah this is like the same thing as
yours right yeah yeah
and i think this is like close to a
thousand bucks this actually broke too
they sent it to me for review and it
broke and then i emailed them and then
they ghosted me oh
wow that's what it's
it's a beast it screams it's super loud
it runs the windows
uh
yeah this one the fans aren't too loud
the speakers are nowhere near as good as
steamed i can tell you that right now um
there's a turbo button here you can hit
and then it basically
makes the hardware go on overdrive at
the expense of battery but it means
better performance
so and it just it feels pretty premium
to hold and to use and it's got a micro
sd card slot here usb ports and
everything and you can attach a keyboard
oh that's cool yeah there's an accessory
i think that's a bit overkill does it
have like a kickstand type thing it does
it has right here oh that's neat yeah no
the same thing right here with a
controller you know but i guess you
could just buy one and then you'd be
fine yeah you can play the steam deck
with a controller yeah yeah bluetooth
bluetooth sync up
i've been docking it too i've been
docking it to a monitor and messing
around with it like that
yeah you can do that with this as well
uh this
but the price is just like i can't
justify the price that's the main thing
that's a lot
just blows it out of the water 100 i
don't know that'd be like six thousand
dollars in australia it's true yeah
that's right i love that competition
exists in that it's kind of encouraged
because it just means we're everyone's
going to try to like top each other and
we're just going to get better devices
from here on out it's an exciting uh
exciting landscape right really sure it
really is um
before we wrap up the other two things
that have come out are kirby has anyone
played it
but i'm playing it tomorrow so i've also
not played it yet but i'm very excited
about it i think it looks awesome me too
me too i've heard nothing but
we missed the destiny expansion thank
you very much
anyway the other one was tiny
[Laughter]
that's fine there's really not much to
talk about other than people seem to
like it you're right people do like it
people do like it it's actually and it's
i think it's kind of broken through as
well with like review the review scene
and like it's getting critical
critically it's really like doing well i
think it's actually one of the highest
rated releases of the year like of
anything like dlc or otherwise
um yeah so critics really love it
players really love it there's obviously
lots of issues with destiny at all times
because right it's that kind of game the
player base is happy
the playbacks are very happy yeah i
stopped two years ago
and did not get back in
um but the raid did look really cool
it's always very cool it's always right
i mean be
i do not recommend anyone watch my
review unless you are a destiny fan with
like way too little in your schedule
okay other than that you were making
everyone honestly better everyone has
better things to do than watch a
one-hour destiny review i will just say
that okay
honestly watch a four-hour video about
deus ex
even if you're not a destiny fan it's a
good video i'd recommend watching
because it's a it's a fun good video
with lots of cool info on it and it
succinctly i think presents what this
patch is and so how many great things
like this game gets right and then the
areas that you said are broken like
you're just feeling way too overpowered
which i totally get like
i didn't watch this hour long video
because i'm not a [ __ ] nerd
you're a different type of nerd we're
all
okay it's just about where we choose to
focus that nerd energy okay
so
okay i will leave a link in the
description because we've obviously lost
over this thing that apparently you have
an hour
worth of uh conversation in your do not
inflict that on your audience okay
all right to spare
uh does anything uh final fantasy come
out
stranger paradise final fantasy oh i
didn't i didn't play it
i played a portion of it okay
it's
man
okay
yeah interesting
the combat is
has a lot of potential but it's marred
by everything else around it the level
design i don't think is very good the
story i don't think
i haven't finished it so i i can't say
for sure but generally i'm hearing by
the time you get to the end it feels
like an unnecessary story and that it's
not really anything super compelling
um
it's basically the neo combat that
carries it in my opinion interesting um
visually graphically it looks like a ps3
game
outright and i've had multiple people uh
sort of echo that sentiment in my circle
of friends and um
it's
it's not a bad game like i think some
people are going to have fun with it
because the combat's really
you know it's flashy but it's got just
the right amount of souls but it's it's
a little more combo based but it's also
got the job
switching system and there are really
cool aspects to that that i commended
for
but
when i don't think that alone can carry
a game and i feel like that's all this
game really has going for it
good combat i think is about the only
praise i can give it based on what i've
played story's not quite there level
design is just i mean i piss poor like
really oh that's a shame level design
like makes it breaks the game for me
yeah it's really like just
a bunch of hallways sometimes it's kind
of you know
interconnected in such a way where you
can get lost because it all kind of
looks the same
there's no mini map and this game really
does need one in my opinion uh
and um
[Music]
yeah uh
it's not super well written either i
don't think like the dialogue is very
weirdly done um the poor i don't know
like
the performances try with what they have
and i you know i don't you can bring
daniel day lewis into this and i don't
think he could make this work
i would love to see that yeah could we
get daniel day-lewis in the next final
fantasy that sounds great
yeah but for this script i don't think
and no matter how good an actor you are
i don't think you can really
make it work like that's a bummer yeah
yeah um so
it's
yeah i'm looking for a good combat
experience maybe that's it yes if you if
you like neo too and are looking for
more of that kind of combat experience
i'd recommend this game in your i think
you're going to have fun because uh the
combat itself i think is fun but i'm not
surprised that the writing wasn't good
based on the trailer the trailer yeah
yeah yeah i don't know man those cut
scenes they look incredible i'm not
really they look like a ride
yeah they look i'll say this like
the way
events play out like it's one of those
like
i guess it's so bad it's good kind of
thing it is entertaining to
watch the bizarreness of how this game
is presented
um
and so there's an entertainment it's not
a forgettable game which is better than
better than nothing yeah yeah yeah but i
wouldn't recommend it to everyone that's
fair that's mixed bag um the only other
thing i was going to ask about before i
let you guys guys go this has been way
longer than i anticipated
uh is
tiny tina's which i've also not played
if you wanted to anyone wanted to give a
synopsis on that if you checked it out
yes kind of burned out on borderlands so
i i've not played i'm not big into
borderlands either but i was really
interested in the look of this it looks
like a thing that that i think i really
enjoy i just haven't tried it the magic
and fantasy elements yes
it's as someone that liked borderlands
but definitely didn't have much
affection for it and that found the
writing completely insufferable uh and
was broadly pretty burnt out on the
borderlands formula i actually quite
like this one i think this has done a
good job i think it's revitalized enough
components of the formula that it
carries it over the line
for example the writing is it's the same
as it was before but the context matters
because when it's a dungeons and dragons
game you forgive all of the ridiculous
cringy sort of improv-esque level
writing because you're like well that's
what happens in a d d campaign people
just riffing and you know some some
funny stuff gets said some crazy stuff
gets there but you keep on rolling you
know
um obviously ashley burch's tiny tina is
doing a huge amount of heavy lifting
throughout all of that but also she her
imagination is manifest in the game
world so she'll be like walking along
and then she'll be like and then all of
a sudden some pirates arrive and then
you look to your left and boom some
pirate ships are there and then some
skeleton army arrives and you turn to
your right and form this guy and like
the fact that she can reshape the world
just by imagining it in front of you i
don't think any game has really done the
d and d
thing like that and i it might it makes
you feel like there should be something
they usually take themselves too
seriously exactly
you never went to nights and whatever
else
yeah of course but like it's a very
different thing versus this just feels
like well how do we just immediately
splash imagination onto the onto the
screen yeah you're right the tone suits
the style of game a lot more than some
of the other orderlands writing yeah
yeah i'm gonna check it out this week
i'm excited about it like it and i also
just like
borderlands diablo sounds fun
like i mean that's what it looks like i
don't know if it plays russian oh i said
it i say yeah yeah i love tabletop i i
play dungeons dragons quite a bit so to
just get all those like references and
the way like those tropes you associate
dnd with and the jokes and the inside
jokes i think that'll be fun i might
check this one out just just it being
structured a little bit differently and
like the building out your character a
little bit differently
made a hell of a difference for me i was
like totally into it especially because
i feel exactly the same way as ralph
where i was like okay borderlands all
right you know this is cool this is very
cool
thanks awesome
uh well thank you for joining me for
like two hours almost not quite we're
not far off i apologize um young what
are you working on right now where can
people find you
uh find me on youtube.com
young yeah i'm actually going to be
reviewing this hunky piece of hardware
and uh
news you know i'll cover them as they
come along um and you know yeah vo if
anyone's interested in voiceover related
stuff and if you just want to hang out
and just like
reach out twit twitter.com slash yangyao
or young yeah um but yeah just leave the
same old working on content whatever
comes next yeah cool jake how about you
uh my youtube channel is my name jake
baldino with a b
uh i'm just kind of
doing whatever right now i think there's
gonna be some more big news this week so
i'm probably gonna be talking about that
uh and then on game ranks uh we're
currently working on i'm gonna cover my
hands in cheeto dust and then i'm gonna
use this and see what happens no not a
good idea very disrespectful to the
device and all the people out there that
can't get their hands on it but oh my
it's what we do it's how we test things
it's a scientific process and it makes a
good thumbnail
you're going to make reddit so mad it's
going to be great
[Music]
uh ralph how about you
uh i am shillop i
am on the youtubes i'm on the twitters
too much and you can google me and
i'm doing weird west at the moment is
anyone else reviewing weird west no what
is that
yeah so it's from it's the okay new
studio from raphael calantonio the
former director of dishonored and prey
it's from with a bunch of arcane vets
it's uh you know an immersive sim set in
a very weird rendition of the wild west
and i'm reviewing that at the moment so
i'm under embargo can't say anything
else reviews out later this week
and then
there is like
a four-month dry spell when nothing is
coming out can i say like there are no
games coming so after that i don't know
what i'm doing man
actually there's lego star wars i think
next week yeah and then oh
it's just chill it's chill time
so uh i'm just gonna like recharge for a
bit i think ahead of like end of year
release schedule which was going to be
bigger until breath of the wild got
bumped now it's just
ragnarok is the last big thing to look
forward to this year like big thing i
mean really big
it's like that that's some things that
haven't been announced that we'll find
out about actually starfield i forgot
starfield yeah
is that coming out this year too i don't
know
i'd be surprised if they honestly this
one i think it is coming out this year
yeah yeah that one i'm a little more
sure about i think we just haven't seen
very much of it they just keep talking
about it
yeah having coffee
you know closer to launch when it's like
more representative of the true product
it's true i'm like don't love the
marketing cycle of being shown things
three years in advance yeah over and
over and over again so i kind of i love
the way that bethesda did their first e3
conferences where it was like and here's
this thing yeah that's out now or like
in three months like i really like that
so yeah that's good that's what they're
trying to do yeah
it'll be interesting to see like it
feels like elden ring right now is sort
of the the sure one to win game of the
year but god of war ragnarok could
that's the one that could potentially
now that breath of life has been pushed
big hill to climb man just gonna say
it's gonna be very true
what god of war has it has that
emotional kind of heart to it that
health and wringing is more the review
is the second fall
but ragnarok has that story that father
son like that like contributes i think a
lot to the game it's in large part why
god of war had such an impact on me is
that father-son story and aspects of it
that were relatable on top of the
incredible game plan i mean
i imagine the set pieces are going to be
on another level with this one i mean
god of war one already like yeah and i
know you can't talk about it but um it
seems like this game's really going for
it and i think maybe as a chance to win
game of the year but eldon rings
i don't know i'm feeling alvin is going
to really secure it it's going to be
really hard to beat that one out we
appreciate your enthusiasm
i don't know much about the game for if
anyone's going to ask because voice
actors don't get told anything now you
just get like your own script and that's
kind of exactly and um
yeah i feel like we're going to get some
more releases before the end of the year
surely that we just don't know about yet
but yeah it does feel like it was like
weirdly front loaded which is like why i
wanted to chat to you guys right now
obviously we had a lot to talk about so
yeah yeah yeah uh thank you all for
joining us i'm sure we'll do this again
thank you
see you bye
[Music]
do it with confidence